okay let's go next
to oh this is interesting i don't think
we've ever had a call from uruguay
let's go to grisha from uruguay
which of course means grasshopper
yes grasshopper i'm calling again mr
pagman i had a call with you a few
months ago oh you did i
apologize i i forgot about it no worries
no need to apologize
and remind me are you are you in you're
in montevideo or are you in colonia
where are you
no i am in montevideo you are here since
like five or six years
got it okay i am originally from
argentina i am from the patagonia
argentina
oh all right beautiful uh-huh so well
first i want to ask you if you are
doing well and i really hope you do i'm
doing well yes thank you
and then i have two really different
uh topics yeah okay one if it is
possible i wanted to ask you in spanish
okay so i recently posted to my
instagram
i was able to obtain a dozen
essentially argentinian croissants which
we call in argentina medialunas which
means like half moon and i think you can
imagine it sort of looks like a crescent
moon
they were they were very good but it was
not
exactly what we would call an
argentinian media luna but
it was pretty good okay
good gracious and and then the second
part for sure is
in english i wanted to ask about if you
have heard
uh this i think is a kind of like a a
leak or a declaration
about the uh but well basically
the u.s influenced brazil to not
take the sputnik vaccine yeah
what have you heard about that i did
hear about it i don't know i mean has it
has it been confirmed
yeah i have seen it in different uh
news sources yeah some from argentina
one that is literally like
sputnik news so it's kind of i don't
know
maybe you go for a different source than
sputnik news but yes i i i know the
allegation has been made
yeah happy player because here norway i
do think that
basically the same happened because uh
the argentinian government offered the
uruguayan government the
vaccine yeah and they were all the way
in government basically like looked to
the other side
and literally waited three more months
to get any vaccine we recently like i
think the first week
of march we had the first xenovac
vaccines right so just uh a question is
like
do you think this is kind of uh
what is left of the policy of
trump trying to uh influence all this
like that latin america in general yeah
i mean listen that goes back
well beyond donald trump and because i
just i don't know the truth of that
story it's hard for me to comment on it
what i do know is that the the we have
this phrase here the proof is in the
pudding
other than chile vaccination in south
america has been a disaster and i'm sure
there are many reasons for it
you know in argentina you might have
seen they make this big
show of an erolinias argentina's playing
plane flying to moscow and then back and
they welcome it at the airport
heroically
and like nobody's getting vaccinated and
meanwhile chile with very
little show has one of the highest
vaccination rates
in in the world and the highest in in
south america
it's like emblematic of the ongoing
problems with a lot of these governments
yeah for sure and then i want to just
one little more because it's a thought
that i have
yeah um trump
talking about show he made a big show
about the
i think it's two billion dollars for the
for the
operation warp speed and yeah things
like that about that
and you have said that operation was uh
worth be it
was a must like if he didn't do
something
to to to put vaccine on uh to work and
uh they that would it would be like
negligent basically
yes uh so i thought about like
maybe he did such a big movement and he
like
moved a lot of money and he didn't get
any results
and that's why he might be oh there
might be some
of this influence to like hey don't get
any other vaccine because i have seen
like tweets and things like that about
not even getting the astra seneca
vaccine or the sinovac
anywhere else get like uh don't get any
other vaccine that is not there
that the us wants i mean listen yes i
thought i had it it's
it's you're it's totally speculative but
it would be very consistent with the way
donald trump sees the world i think we
can say that
yeah it's full of speculation at 100
percent for sure i don't have any source
but yeah uh well nothing else david
big a big hug america
and have a beautiful day hey grisha
before you go one question when i was in
montevideo a few years ago
i went to uh correct me if i'm wrong the
the
the market downtown is it el mercado
it was amazing and it's like this indoor
market with all these different
you know uh food stands there were so
many americans there
humiliating themselves and attracting a
lot of attention is that
common that american tourists at the
mercado del puerto
embarrass themselves yeah they kind of
do and not only there
i work in a hotel that is basically on
the opposite side
of montevideo yeah and right behind that
there is a really good grill you know
like a really
like a grill that is there since the 60s
so they do know what they are doing
and it's really really useful to to to
see the faces of the
of the people serving there like i
cannot believe it oh no that's
that's humiliating nowhere is there
there are plenty of
uh people from anywhere in the world i'm
guessing getting
humiliated humiliated sorry that's true
markets everywhere all over the world
yes it's not unique to uruguay or
america all right grisha appreciate the
call thank you
for sure david have a beautiful day all
right you too all right guys
let's end on a perfect phone call i
don't know that we could have had a more
perfect phone call than that
i apologize as always that i'm not able
to get to everyone
but we'll keep taking calls and i'll
keep hearing from many more of you